أوه ، نحن لسنا مختلفين عن أي شخص آخر في
المجتمع ، لسنا مختلفين عن
جيراننا ، لكننا جميعًا متشابهون ، نحن
بريطانيون ، سنرى ما سيأتي
من بوريس الآن بعد أن أصبح رئيسًا للوزراء
لأنني لا  أعتقد أنه سيكون
لدينا نفس العلامة التجارية بوريس إلى كيف
سيكون كرئيس للوزراء متهمًا
بالإسلاموفوبيا في الماضي ، قلت إن
النساء المسلمات اللواتي يرتدين الحجاب في صناديق البريد ولصوص البنوك ،
هل تقبل كلماتك لها
عواقب عليك ذلك
القوة وبقدر ما أساءت إليه كلماتي على
مدار العشرين أو الثلاثين
عامًا الماضية عندما كنت صحفيًا
وأخذ الناس هذه الكلمات من
مقالاتي وصعّدوها بالطبع ،
أنا آسف على الإساءة التي أعتقد أنها كانت
جيدة.
من الواضح أن الشيء المحتمل
حول المسلم ،
ما هو المستقبل الذي
سيكون لنا كمجتمع مسلم ، سنطلب
منه الوفاء بوعده بإجراء
تحقيق مستقل في
الحزب المحافظ فيما يتعلق
بالإسلاموفوبيا هو عرض رئيس وزرائنا
بالنسبة إلينا القيم البريطانية التي كانت
بوريس العلامة التجارية لدينا الآن بوريس رئيس
الوزراء
[موسيقى]
تجربتي اليومية لكوني مسلمة في
بريطانيا جيدة بشكل عام ، حيث
تسمح لي الحكومة في الواقع بالحصول على
حرية التعبير وممارسة
معتقداتي في
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يبدأ العمل ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك لأننا
جزء من نسيج المجتمع ، لذا فإن
مخاوفنا بشأن بوريس جونسون هي
نفس اهتمامات الآخرين
[الموسيقى]